the british government insists it'll
carry on with its plan to send unwanted
asylum seekers to rwanda despite
widespread criticism the uk wants to
prevent migrants coming to its shores
through unauthorized routes so it's
threatening any such potential arrivals
that they'll be expelled to rwanda in
return rwanda is getting 150 million
dollars and a chance to promote itself
as a hospitable haven
rwanda is offering asylum seekers up to
five years stay with access to education
and support human rights groups say the
uk is shunning its responsibility to
grant protection to asylum seekers
sending them to a country with a
questionable human rights record this is
all wrong
this
deal
for so many different reasons
the precedent that this creates is
catastrophic
for a concept that needs to be shared
like asylum
the first deportation was supposed to
take place this past tuesday but the
european court of human rights issued an
injunction that kept that plan from
taking off
it was a last-minute intervention the
first plane bound for kigali with seven
asylum seekers on board never left the
tarmac
a setback but the british government is
undeterred the home secretary confirmed
that preparations for future flights
were already underway
but even from within rwanda there is
criticism of the deportation deal
the migrants will be sent back to their
starting point because rwanda is not a
country that respects human rights
there's no democracy
they fled their country and they are
sent to a country where they will find
themselves facing the same situation
rwanda already hosts more than a hundred
thousand refugees from other african
countries
peter naoni fled the civil war in south
sudan eight years ago
he was moved here last year by the
united nations refugee agency
but doesn't want to stay
i just want to go ahead
if it is europe or canada i would just
go but not to stay here
he feels sorry for the migrants who will
be sent to rwanda from the uk
because they will have to apply for
asylum here
the uk government is
my message to them is that
human beings are human
you cannot tell them
go and stay here or go and do this and
do this no
because if they feel better in uk uk is
better for them
it's not a message the british or the
rwandan government want to hear
this hostel in kigali is ready to house
the first migrants sent under the new
deal
its general manager said it was not a
prison despite tight security measures
an opinion that may not be shared by
some of the new arrivals
let's bring in charles and dushabhandi a
freelance journalist based in kigali
rwanda charles it's good to have you on
the program
now what is rwanda offering these people
deported from the uk
yes what they want to say is
what is saying that they are offering
them a fresh start drive
some will be offered those who are
willing to stay here will be offered
student ships and will become citizens
here be given skills
so that they can be integrated into
society and look for jobs like any other
one
okay um so what about for rwanda it's
going to receive some money from the uk
120 million pounds but
why else is rwanda doing this apart from
the money
it's about apart from the money 120
million pounds for the start
that was like some sort of a signing fee
signing argument fee the money that was
meant for that is meant for development
partnerships and what
but there is much more money that is
going to be involved money money that is
going to be used to pay for the hostels
they are going to be staying in because
they are renting them from
one of the associations that has been
managing associations of
the genocide against two survivors
so apart from that money als also
the water government says that they are
doing it on humanitarian grounds
having for them also been having been
refugees in the past
they believe
they owe
the world support support other migrants
and refugees but however
some others and others if you'd see it
very well others say that
it's how it's being used by the
government as a political tool
they are trying to do partnerships with
with the uk government that partnership
will help the women government
to create its image
as one of the countries that is working
together with the west with the west
side of the migrant and asylum country
the west is facing currently
right now you mentioned rwanda's history
when it comes to
being refugees but what is rwanda's
track record when it comes to hosting
migrants and refugees
it's guaranteed one that hosts around
130 southern refugees in different
countries
those are made from the receiver of the
republic of congo and burundi
but the one also see
refugees from afghanistan including
those from an organ school
that are staying around chicago and are
studying from here
also there are some other migrants who
came
in the past came from
came from israel also comprised of
illegal ethiopians but most of them they
stayed here for a short period of time
and left
there are some i talked to recently who
have located sudan because they said the
rifling water was unbearable so i don't
know
how that will change for these migrants
that are being brought in from the uk
all right charles du chabandi speaking
to us from kigali many thanks for your
time
thank you welcome
you